last time you did a really good
animation about top-down parsing we had
these sentences in this totally
artificial grammar which is only got
about 30 words in it all in all but we
started here with sentences subject verb
object and in the top-down approach you
basically say okay I'll push those on
the stack in reverse order subject verb
object and starting at the top of the
stack at the left you say well what can
i sub ject B so you do these things on
your stack top down one at a time and
you start off at the root of the tree
and you develop the component parts left
to right one at a time it is a lot
easier totally by hand to write a
top-down parsing run the bottom-up one
but what I should be getting to later on
and in fact I'm starting right now is to
say well what happens if instead of
starting up at the root and developing
the leaves of the tree as it were you
start right down at the bottom with the
texturing that you know is correct and
try and work upwards you know can you
work back upwards from the leaves to the
root
in fact let's write that test sentence
below here the robot stroked two furry
I'm actually since layout doesn't matter
too much at the moment I'll squeeze the
word dicing at the right there
now be clear we're talking about
bottom-up parsing now in bottom-up
parsing you start with the string that
you are think is correct and you say
start with a string can I look into the
rules and see how to work up the tree
not down the tree and yes so therefore
you're looking at possible matches on
the right hand side for components of
this string reading from left to right
okay though how many ways are there you
can match the string there against one
of these classifications here well the
text the string there is the right hand
side possibility of an article that's
one way to do it oh and then look up
here right at the top of the grammar if
you have an article followed by a noun
like the followed by something else that
could be a subject and that's looking
good goes right up at the top of the
grammar we want to end up with subject
verb object looking just at the robot
and looking at the grammar right hand
sighs I could do it by saying well it's
the subject of the sentence it's at the
left hand side and if I go article now
and I get there and I get robot but what
I've done just to act as a talking point
and it illustrates a lot of things here
I've given you a shortcut if you want to
you can just do the robot with no
further interior analysis at all it's an
allowed phrase it's the subject now I
have to say that as we develop this
story we will get into bottom-up pausing
because one of the tools were going to
use call deaq basically produces
bottom-up pauses for you not top-down
one
and it's a yak behavior symptom that it
loves when you're trying to match text
rings
it likes to match the longest one that
it can manage so it is going to seize on
the robot all as one phrase as being a
wonderful long solution why doesn't it
you sue there and then wait patiently
for noun that's not the bottom up way if
you can see a longer oh and this thing
by the way that you're looking at is
built upon a stack of course it's called
the handle I get a longer handle by
going for this option here and getting
the robot all in one go okay the robot
then and you've got to get used to
reading from right to left now in
bottom-up parsing the robot all is water
phrase is an example of a subject so we
can now say okay the robot is my subject
now that's act of picking up a substring
from your sentence and going upwards and
making it more abstract if you like it's
called reducing in bottom-up parsing so
looking for a longer and longer and
longer string to get your handle that's
called shifting because you're shifting
characters one after another and making
a string longer and longer and saying
can I go any further south shifting but
when you say all that's a nice long
string and it matches and they will go
up and say oh that's my subject that is
called reduction because you're going to
something simpler further up the tree so
you can tick that off as being done
bottom up next thing is you see this
string of characters called stroke and
once again it's right hand side driven
what it is there on the right hand side
and which rule is it that could possibly
match stroked you see in here against
verb bit kicked I'll stroke those three
strings on your possibilities so it's
fine going right to left you say stroked
is an example of a verb
so we've got our verb there now again
cheated but it's wonderful fun I have
not analyzed two furry dice in two
adjectives and now
I've just put it in as a interesting
shortcut to have there and it is an
example of what I would call an object
phrase some of you who are really good
English language may want to go on about
my lack of understanding about what to
direct and indirect object or not to
mention predicates and so on but please
forgive me I regard it as being a phrase
in an object position so I'm saying
there's a quick match here and bottom
asking I love this to furry dice a great
long hand law oh and if I've match it
there
what's the left-hand side it corresponds
to oh okay then we've won we have worked
bottom up to having subject verb object
on our stack starting with the string
and what's more we've exhausted the
string now it's the end of it there's a
sort of full stop after that there we
are then
we've got top down which tends to be
more she was eager you know a top-down
pars would very probably leap on the
word though and not bother to go any
further because he's found a quick match
whereas bottom-up is the other way round
it's basically saying I want the longest
possible handle even at this stage in
the late fifties and early sixties there
was a sneaky suspicion coming around
that actually bottom-up parsing was a
little bit more powerful than top-down
I'm gonna put out a set of notes for
this so that you can look up for
yourself just examples of why it is more
powerful but roughly speaking I think
you can sense that because you've not
only got something you're looking for
but you've got a handle that you've
already accumulated it's like gathering
more contextual information going
bottom-up but on the other hand handling
the stack and working out what's
happening is adults more complicated if
you do it by hand coming bottom up round
the dudes all by hand
why not me and you not it's a good way
to learn lex and yak in other words
don't write the c directly yourself get
a software tool of these like these two
to do it for you so that's exactly what
we're going to do i've got the program
see that does ssh connected here I'm
talking to my other Linux machine in the
other room where I have got set up a
pawza complete parser front-end lexical
analyzer syntax analysis for this furry
grammar and all legal sentences in it
and I know first of all you will want me
to call up the program that implements
this and the test sentence first of all
is the robots throat too far we go so
furry
is hanging there it's waiting for us to
give a correct furry sentence dice
return look at that it's happy with it
I'm givin it to in subject-verb-object
order and I have numbered those rules in
the grammar as I showed you earlier and
I now have as it were a map of how it
has passed it rule 3
now that is the one that effectively
says I can do the robot all as one
phrase it has chosen not to go for the
and robot this article and now as
separate entities mi will have done that
had I gone top-down but because this yak
conflicted parser system goes bottom-up
it's gone for the longest possible
handle of a stage and it's matched it
rule for the middle piece is matched
stroked as the verb and finally it just
spotted right at the very end that I put
in another sneaky shortcut to furry
dices rule of 6 and that is my pars so
should we try one more just to make sure
gon show and tell me what you want to
try the woman bit the dog yep a woman
bit the dog
now look rule to the woman now rule to
not rule 3 if it's folded rule 2 it's
gone down the article noun root which
means it knows that's the only way to
match the water the woman there is no
shortcut way ok
rule 4 a verb rule again you chose B
rule 5 now this time again there is no
shortcut to 2 furry dice that rule say
you've got to go the long way around a
following rulefive you break it down
into Article now and again though and
dog so there we are we you could say
well you've written a compiler for the
furry language with the help of Lex and
yak we could go into details of that
later if need be but not now it's very
nothing it's not doing anything really
is it what more shall we do with this
now we've written in this father oh you
tell me well I think next time we need
to come up with direction it needs to do
something with needs to transform that
grammar in some way those of his those
of you who in the previous video
actually bother to look at the extra
bits may have had a sneak preview as to
what we're going to do as our much more
interesting actions now we have
recognized the innate structure so
remember always watch the extra bits
computer scientists began to say well
you know this is great because if we're
writing a computer language like Algol
60 we can have the whole of the Algol 60
grammar displayed to us and as we're
writing it in assembler or whatever we
could have half an eye on what to do
next because